(upbeat music)
(scooter revving)
- [Evan] Alright Nina, Nina's
going to do some hula hooping.
The hula hoop challenge, here it is, hey!
Ho ho, nice, okay my turn.
(upbeat music)
Come on Catherine, what you got.
Ho, you okay?
- I smashed my face.
- [Evan] You smashed your face, alright.
(upbeat music)
Whoa, whoa, he's got it, whoa.
It's all in the hips, good job Jeffery,
high five up there mister, boom.
(upbeat music)
Oh, nice that was pretty good.
- I know.
- High five, boom.
Doesn't matter if you
know how to do it or not.
Give it a try, have some fun.
Don't care what people
around you think of you
making a fool of yourself.
All that matters is you, right?
Give it a shot, stop being so afraid.
That's it, have a great weekend guys.
We believe in you, we hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, we'll see you soon.